they found my paper they're in Key
Biscayne where they work as that that
made it up the president's mind he would
renounce toxins no matter how they're
made whether they're made by living
things or by chemists in factories and
so that put toxins and living biological
weapons in the same category the United
States renounced them both President
Nixon also at that same time expressed
support for the British draft treaty it
was a British treaty not ours to
prohibit biological weapons to which we
added toxins a worldwide and some years
later that Trujillo came into force
after a considerable negotiation boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sakia we are on-site
at the biological laboratories building
at Harvard in the beautiful Cambridge
Massachusetts we are now going to be
talking about everything from beneficial
versus hostile uses of biology banning
biological weapons preventing
existential risk and so much more we are
honored and blessed to be sitting down
with dr. Matthew meselson hello thank
you for coming on to the show really
appreciate it we're very grateful to
have you on very grateful for max
tegmark for introducing us and making
this conversation happen for those who
don't know Matthews background he
consulted with Henry Kissinger and
assisting Richard Nixon to renounce
biological and toxin weapons ensuring
that the ever more powerful science of
biology helps rather than harms
humankind winning the 2019 future of
life award for this work he also with
his colleagues proved Watson and Crick's
hypothesis on how DNA replicates solved
the Sverdlovsk anthrax mystery and ended
the use of Agent Orange in Vietnam he
has been at Harvard University for
almost 60 years and is a professor in
the department of molecular and cellular
biology and you can check out the links
below to Matthew's work all right
Matthew let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions which is what
is your take on the direction
of our world I think that we are as a
species approaching what you might call
an inflection point there are a number
of things which are going to change the
environment in which we think and in
which we live one of them of course is
the almost certain development of
guiding our own future evolution not
today not tomorrow but eventually we
will be changing our genomes we will be
guiding our own evolution we will be
living not just on this planet there
will be set of human settlements on
other planets
starting with Mars we will be relying
not only on our own minds or even on
what today are called advanced computers
there will be computers of such great
power but they don't merely answer the
questions that we pose they will be
posing questions and they will be
perhaps even giving orders furthermore
the whole structure of the world economy
will change in ways that cannot be
foreseen but at least at present the
extreme inequality of the distribution
of wealth drives social unrest and the
ability to see what's happening over the
web means that people see this
inequality and climate change will also
drive migrations of people so a large
number of things including those and
some others are going to cause rapid and
profound change by rapid I don't mean
tomorrow but the time span which I'm
thinking is of maybe centuries it's
wrong to think that the human beings are
a fixed species we've been evolving up
to this point we continue really long we
are just too
snapshot of the makeup of the human race
they will continue to change maybe even
split up into varieties maybe even
species so that can happen only of
course if you have human populations
with no communication between them but
if very widely separated bodies and
space become populated travel between
them might be so unusual and I'm not
talking about tomorrow I'm not a
wild-eyed science fiction person but we
have for what two thousand years of
reasonably decent human history to
project another two thousand years given
this pace of change since since I was
born even biology it was only about a
less than 150 years ago that it was
discovered that cells come from other
cells and not just from some sort of goo
and in that time look how far we've come
through most of it with very simple
instruments a rather poor microscope
maybe a Bunsen burner until now we have
what at least today we would think of
extremely sophisticated microscopes and
all kinds of other things but why should
the pace of improvement in our ability
to probe nature slow down it won't we
will be able to probe nature and modify
nature to a degree that's difficult to
think of now unless you read Isaac
Asimov or Clark or one of those science
fiction writers so we need to think
about that and what is it we need to
think about well I'd say the thing we
need to think about her one of the
things we need to think about is in all
of this change what is it that we want
not to change and I would say then what
we want not to change and even to
enhance is our humanity so that leads to
the question of what is our humanity
what is it that we most value in being
human
is it the feeling that nearly all human
beings have when you are helping someone
or being useful to someone being loved
by someone whether a family member or an
organization which you serve this
generally gives pleasure if you're if
you feel unneeded uncared-for by anybody
or by any organization by any outfit I
don't think there are many people who
would find that Pleasant and it's that
feeling which has allowed us to
cooperate
there's no way in which complete
individuals if we were like the male
lions who go off by themselves except to
mate all of us entity unto itself
we couldn't build homes we couldn't do
anything together we couldn't do science
really because that requires also
collaboration so that's one that another
thing is the feeling of awe I think we
value that a lot another is curiosity we
value that a lot compassion so I don't
think that we've even seriously written
down and thought about what is the most
essential thing if we continue to evolve
even in the natural manner but of course
now greatly speeded up by intervention
what is it we want not to change so how
do you decide on that it seems to me you
need not just mileages you need
humanists what we need to do a small
scale say here at Harvard University's
is try and interest the very best young
scientists and the very best young
humanists to get together something
which doesn't happen now to begin
thinking about these things we need the
very best young scientists perhaps now
here I'm not a humanist so I can only
talk as a rank amateur but maybe to read
Aeschylus and Sophocles and Euripides
because those ancient Greek playwrights
we're asking basically what is the right
relationship between you
what is the right relationship between
the individual in the state what is the
good life what is virtue so it's very
hard to be more specific about these
things because not much thought has gone
into them but it would be good to begin
now even though it's a very long way off
but I'm sure it will happen unless some
kind of disaster overwhelms us before
that sooner or later
barukh real disaster we will be
determining our own evolution a long
time from now don't get the idea I'm
saying that's tomorrow it's not and I'm
not talking about the domain of
bioethicists that's different
bio ethics has to do with the immediate
consequences that you might lose your
privacy that you might um begin to
discriminate between people in an unfair
way because of some genetic attribute
things like that that's important but
it's not bioethics that's needed for the
problem I'm addressing it's needed for
other problems the problem I'm
addressing is the long-term future of
our species so now I think the question
to which I've given this long-winded
answer is so what is your concern about
human race if reoccurring theme that's
so well synthesized then it seems as
though a reoccurring theme of what you
stand for is our process of slowing down
and thinking and making better choices
or maybe hurry up and make better
choices yeah yeah awakened faster
climate change we better hurry up
because that is a clicking top [ __ ]
clock yeah it has clicked quite a bit
sore many of the other things that you
listed that was very well synthesized
let's get into the journey Matthew so
born initially in Denver then grew up in
Los Angeles but you you got you had this
really cool upbringing where you had
Natural Sciences present in your home
when you're tinkering I had a big
laboratory in the basement rather in the
garage of my family home and I did a lot
of chemistry before I went to a college
and that's a reoccurring theme of people
that we sit down with this that they had
the tools that they needed when they
were younger to be able to fill that
curiosity well I loved science and in
particular like mathematics and physics
and chemistry for even younger age I
think my parents told me that when I was
2 and 3 I used to fool around with
little lights and wires and batteries
it's hard to know why this some people
doing the very same family a group of
siblings someone want one thing some
another but it cuz you can see these
tendencies in some people not not even
the majority very early and that in
itself is we'd like to understand that
better yeah a lot of that is the how
things work curious and then this led
you to doing chemistry at the University
of Chicago well I didn't actually okay
teacher suppose I went to high school in
Los Angeles and during the war that's
the Second World War I think a lot of
kids felt that it was not right to just
goof off during the summer the war on so
on you should do something more serious
like get a job or take summer courses I
did both one summer I got a job in a
defense factory and one summer I took
extra courses at Hollywood high and at
the end of that summer I went to the
Registrar at my high school
Thomas rather John Marshall High School
and said I've now got all the academic
requirements to be graduated could I
have my diploma and she said no
according to California state law you
have to have three full years of
physical education yeah well I really
stunned me because I thought that up
till then that the adults in this world
no bitter in all regards and here was a
really silly regulation so I began to
ask well how can I escape this the
Registrar at the high school said why
don't you just take the courses that you
like over again and so it was something
like desserts you have a second helping
but that makes no sense when it comes to
taking courses and so eventually
somebody told me there was a place that
would take students who had not finished
high school and this was the University
of Chicago and I thought oh good
university I can start studying
chemistry and physics and math and I got
there I was 16 and it turns out the
robert maynard hutchins had abolished
the bachelor's degree in any specialized
subject instead it was a great books
program you read the classics you read
the really important books about
sociology about economics about art and
so on but there was no course in
chemistry no course in physics for
undergraduates so I didn't get a degree
in science from the University of
Chicago I'd got a degree called Bachelor
of philosophy then I left College for a
whole year wandering around Europe and
then I went back to Chicago for one more
year now I could take specialized
courses but still I didn't have a
bachelor's degree in any science subject
which is what you saw when you went to
Europe
I saw a land will I went to Paris I went
to Czechoslovakia Hungary Italy parents
wasn't too badly destroyed but there was
at that time very little traffic on the
streets there were bullet holes in
buildings but one thing that was very
impressive was that there were Americans
there but they weren't tourists they
were jeez would come back after the war
to Paris most of them I think or at
least many of them or more accurately
what came across to me was that these
were guys who were wondering okay we
fought this terrific war what's it all
about well what is the future going to
be they came to Paris maybe because of
the romance of it but also with
questions on their mind so you're
sitting cafes and overhear conversations
of that kind so then I wanted to go and
see the Soviet Union here during the war
they were our great allies and now
already by 1949 which is the year I was
the first child was in Europe they were
beginning to be our great enemies so I
was confused what's what's the score
here and I have always wanted to make up
my own mind about things including that
so I thought the best way and being I
guess just because I'm scientifically
inclined you have to go see you have to
get the data so I thought in my young
way I got to get over there and see what
it's like so I went to the Soviet
embassy in Moscow in the Paris and they
said oh you have to be invited by
somebody well I didn't know anybody
there so then I went to Budapest there
was a communist youth festival there and
hungry had just become communist so I
went to the Soviet embassy there and
said can I get a visa to go to Russia no
you have to be invited by someone while
I did know so I never got to the Soviet
Union on that trip but Hungary had just
turned communist
and the law had been passed to prevent
you make it a crime to listen to the BBC
the British Broadcasting System at first
the people I was living with just didn't
believe it
but then one of them took me to the
library and we looked up the records
from the Parliament and sure enough a
few weeks before a law had been passed
that made it a crime to listen to the
BBC which really turned me off on
communism even though a lot of the
objectives that that they announced were
worthwhile objectives but the means by
which they were trying to impose these
objectives were antithetical to free
thinking and science so this left me in
a kind of a wandering situation what
should I do in myself and at first I
thought I'd maybe become a psychiatrist
but a funny kind of psychiatrist I would
treat not individuals with nations that
is I would try and think about how wars
that represent a kind of pathology man
but I couldn't get very far thinking
that way and I furthermore thought at
the end of my life I'd like to feel that
whatever I had done during my life was
correct and in something like psychology
how would you know
whereas in something like chemistry
which may be much more dull than
throwing it out how to prevent war at
least if you worked properly you'd know
that what you've done was correct like
if you got the formula of some molecule
estructura some molecule did it properly
it's correct it's gonna last anyway I
came back home I went to Caltech for a
year because now I could go to a real
technical place and had to start all
over again there was a freshman and I
didn't like it because teaching then was
remote bye-bye oh sorry not remote but
was by rote except for the course by
Linus Pauling away I liked that course a
lot and so I left Caltech after when you
went back to the University of Chicago
for a year and then I got a letter from
them that said we don't give the
bachelor's degree in physics but if we
did we give one
- Matthew meselson that got me into the
physics department at Berkeley which I
didn't like too much because it was huge
the classes were gigantic so here I am
wandering bouncing around between
Caltech Chicago and Berkeley and finally
I got to know Linus Pauling's children
two of his children during the time I
was at Caltech and one of them I think
it was his daughter Linda I had a party
at their house the swimming pool and I'm
in the swimming pool swimming around and
out comes the world's greatest chemist
Linus Pauling and he knew me because I
had done a little research project for
him when I was a freshman there and he
said what are you gonna do next year I
said I was going to go to study with a
man named Nicholas reshef ski at the
University of Chicago and Pauling said
that's a lot of baloney come be my
graduate student and I looked up by the
water and I said okay I will so that's
how he got to be his student and from
then on I think my career was pretty set
I did x-ray crystallography for Linus
but it was crystallography to teach me
the structure of molecule is important
for life because to do molecular biology
you need to know molecular structure and
then my god it is to the problem of DNA
replication and together with my friend
Frank saw install we sold how DNA
replicates namely semi conservatively
and teaches about when you're first
doing x-ray crystallography and then
when you're learning about and
confirming the DNA replication process
teach us about that time period well
there's a long and a short version but
the short version is that we had an idea
from something completely different
something a problem that was posed by a
visiting famous French scientist Giacomo
know the problem having nothing to do
with DNA structure but at that time the
proposal of Watson Crick for the
structure for the replication of DNA was
controversial because they had a lot of
problems I won't go into detail but the
big problem was that to separate those
two strands unless you're going to break
them you have to unwind the I wrote
the entire unreplicated part of the
molecule and if it's a very big molecule
and chromosomes have very big molecules
of DNA the viscous drag of rotating the
unreplicated molecule is absolutely
prohibitive you couldn't get that much
work done inside the living cell
if you break strands then you could
rotate around the single moms'
it's a little bit complicated but not
very complicated so there were several
different hypotheses but the basic idea
of the two initial strands each acting
as a template for the production of two
new sisters strands that's correct
strands do get broken though not in the
way that it was being thought about in
those days but in a different way and it
occurred to me that we could
discriminate these different methods of
replication by labeling DNA molecules
with a heavy isotope by growing bacteria
we eventually got the bacteria at first
we thought we could do this this
bacteriophage by me by we I mean my
friend Frank Stoll and me we labeled
bacteria with a heavy isotope of the
element nitrogen you can buy nitrogen 15
which is a heavier form of nitrogen as
one more Neutron in the nucleus and then
plunge these bacteria that had been
growing in a heavy nitrogen medium into
a medium that was ordinary nitrogen and
now if you could just distinguish
molecules of different density in a very
subtle way so we worked for a year or so
to develop a method to do that there had
been no method to do that and we did
develop a method for doing that and then
we applied that method to this problem
and we observed and what turned out to
be a very beautiful way that after one
replication all the DNA molecules have
one old chain and one new one just like
Watson and Crick had predicted and after
two generations half the DNA molecules
would be completely new and half would
have one old chain and one new chain etc
etc it was a very very visual proof it
had another value some people didn't
believe the structure of DNA was that as
proposed by Watson and Crick I think
that was partly because some people felt
biology is very complicated and so the
gene must be very complicated you know
there's too simple to be true and others
felt it was too simple to be wrong to be
so be wrong and the fact was that what
they had proposed was a model there was
no real evidence that was correct it
fitted the requirements of structural
chemistry but that didn't prove it was
right so I think our experiment by
showing these bands on photographs from
an ultracentrifuge exactly as predicted
by their replication scheme had a big
psychological effect now in fact I think
Jim writes in his book the double helix
that it was that that made him feel the
relief of knowing that yeah of course
they were right that is the structure of
DNA in fact the real structures of the
changer wound around each other wasn't
finally proved until quite a few years
later by Crick and Jim Wong like a
completely different kind of experiment
so anyway what a profound time in
biology
yes and I'll tell you why it was
profound this DNA molecule told us what
to do if you look at the structure of a
molecule of a protein or a lipid it says
nothing or almost nothing if you look at
that DNA model it says Here I am I have
two strands I'm a gene I have to
replicate how do I do it go out and find
out how here I am I have these four
different bases you can put information
in this writing of four letters that
writing must tell you what proteins to
make what sequence of amino acids go
find out how that's done Here I am once
in a while there's a change it's called
mutation go figure out how that happened
so here I am once in a while
a piece of me gets broken and stuck onto
a piece of another DNA molecule that's
called recombination go
how that happened so here I am what's
the while there's an accident and then
copied incorrectly but there's a
mechanism for correcting me go figure
in other words this molecule was
dictating what had to be done and to me
that allows us to define in the era when
all the questions that DNA was demanding
that you go out and solve giving orders
really when those all got their basic
answers I mean there are a lot of
details they were still studying but
when the basic questions were all in
that's the end of that era that's the
period from about 1953 till roughly
speaking 1970 or something like that and
now it would be almost wrong to call it
molecular biology well you could call it
that but it was a very different period
of time at that time visualizing this
edge of knowledge in biology been opened
up and then all of those questions that
you listed that then people could
inquire about and Yelton you pushing and
it gave orders it literally stood there
and told you what to do unusual yeah to
have that much of an edge be opened up
and also for the edge to be the code of
life yeah it was the code of life it was
the big boss determining what research
should be done and we were all just the
graduate students it was the professor
yes and another another aspect of that
tying it all the way to what you
mentioned the very beginning about how
now being in control of what was the
professor is incredibly just in just the
timespan of 70 years we are now in
control of what used to be well we're
beginning to be it's still there people
talk about CRISPR Cassadine that's very
good but it's not perfect by a long shot
and even when we get it which we do not
have
methods of precisely with no accidents
changing one DNA sequence to another one
whether it's replacing one gene with
another or just replacing one base with
another we cannot do that with
perfection yeah but that's easy that'll
be done no problem there's a much bigger
problem
it's called epistasis so the problem of
off target effects or even nearby target
effects
that'll be soft but most gene products
both proteins and even RNA interact with
other gene products an amazingly
complicated way so one protein might
bind either permanently or temporarily
with some other protein or the whole
mess of other proteins now when you've
changed one gene if you change it
perfectly exactly the way you want it
what you don't know is all the ways in
which the protein coded for by that gene
might be working together with other
proteins so if you change this one
you've changed all these interactions
now it's going to be a long time before
we understand that but maybe that's
where supercomputers maybe even quantum
computers will be of real help because
that requires taking one huge amount of
detailed information and figuring out
what it means
so changing our own heredity will
require because of this problem of alpha
stasis which I may be exaggerating or I
may be under emphasizing only when that
is solved can we safely
of course we'll start doing it safely or
not just like this gentleman and China
did with the two little girls from whom
he exercised the gene that makes you
susceptible to the AIDS virus there's
some claim somewhere and I haven't read
the paper yet but they what this and
when this is done with mice the mice get
smarter that things they can run mazes
better a lot depends on that in a way
because if those two little girls turn
out to be desperately ill as a result
that'll put a monkey wrench in the
gene modification business for quite a
while not permanently but if it turns
out that they're smarter the floodgates
will be slightly pried open so a lot
depends on individual events at least
over the short term but over the long
term human beings are going to be
guiding their own evolution the problem
is that a which human beings well only
the rich ones of course there's a
problem there of course it's only part
of the general problem of the inequality
of the distribution of the wealth which
we produce and which nature offers it's
distributed very unequally and people
are beginning to understand that because
they can see also the nature of
capitalism and see now here I'm a
biologist so don't take any of this too
seriously but the nature of capitalism
has changed because if I for example am
an owner of a big automobile factory I
have to spend my my revenue the total
money is pretty to buy steel and a
rubber machines I have to pay a large
workforce so a lot of it goes out to
other people the miners who mined the
iron to make this day and so on if I
invented Facebook I don't need much
stuff for that I need some offices I
need some computers a higher few people
but not multitudes of people don't need
extract but in the rules I've got
multitudes of people paying me draining
money from a multitude of people into a
very few people now that's ok if the
very few people spend it but they don't
spend it they allow it to accumulate
they so that we have more and more money
that's accumulating and accumulating now
here I'm talking really without much
knowledge but it seems to me that in
this sense that capitalism is failing us
it's not it's certainly making better
things still entrepreneurs and all that
but it is not distributing the wealth in
a way that will make the society
coherent and stable yeah you know the
the instability that we face with wealth
inequality is hazardous and we need a
better way of addressing what's
happening you brought up the great
excellent point of this just the sheer
scaling ability of software and you also
bring up again just how pressing of an
issue this is to figure out how to
tackle we talked about this very
frequently on the show and we look
forward to the new codes that are
implemented what is this new code of a
way that incentivizes innovation while
simultaneously takes in new markers of
well-being into our world so you being
at the edge of genetics and molecular
biology has been happening for a while
in the Harvard faculty again since 1960
constantly professing as well there's
still so much more to understand about
the career in genetics and molecular
biology but I also really want to hit
into deeper into this point in 1963 you
became a resident consultant for the
United States arms control and
disarmament agency and then you were you
were viewing the base where they we were
manufacturing anthrax and you were like
why are we manufacturing anthrax and
that led you into this incredible work
with biological weapons and the
renouncing them so please teach us about
this well I got to the Arms Control
Agency more or less by accident they
wanted to hire six academics just for
the summer to think up some new ideas
for them it was a new agency in the
State Department building and I had a
friend who had a beautiful house in
Georgetown they would be completely
empty and so this seemed very attractive
something to do different from science
but only for the summer and also a very
nice place to live and explore so I went
down there and they said okay you're
going to work on the European theater
nuclear arms-control which I knew
absolutely nothing that's okay because
scientists often feel
arrogant enough to think that they can
always do something useful in any field
but the problem was that an awful lot of
other people did know a lot about it
books and papers and so on so I asked my
boss since I'm a chemist and a biologist
couldn't you let me think about chemical
or biological arms control he said you
do whatever you want we're all going off
to the through Moscow to negotiate the
atmospheric nuclear test-ban so I
decided I better go over to the CIA and
see what we thought other countries were
doing and at that time the answer was we
didn't know very much
we had some suspicions and then I went
over to Fort Dietrich in Maryland where
our principal place for research and
development of biological weapons was
and the nice man took me around and he
was Leroy Fothergill an immunologist
colonel and we came to a building seven
stories high that had what looked like
windows if you were far away from it but
when you get up close they're phony
windows I guess - so spies could not
tell from a distance what was all about
and I asked what's in there I can't
remember if he took me inside or not but
he said we have been there a 10,000
gallon fermenter and we make anthrax
spores there and I said this a long time
ago so I'm thinking I'm remembering it
but the gist of it is right I said what
do we do that for
he said well it'll save us money it's a
lot cheaper than nuclear weapons as a
weapon of mass destruction it's a fairly
long taxi ride back from Fort Detrick in
Maryland to the State Department
building in Washington and somewhere I
think it was during a taxi and don't owe
me a weight cheap we don't want there to
be a cheap weapon of mass destruction
for example what if I invented a
hydrogen bomb that cost a nickel we want
war to be so cool I would like more to
be so expensive that nobody could afford
it that'd be great
and of course as an American I would
like more to be so expensive that only
the United States could afford it all
right that seems maybe a little bit too
nationalistic but so it seemed to me
that not only was this a dumb thing to
do
but there was a marvelous argument for
not doing it on top of which it was my
science I'm a biologist and I could see
because it was just the beginning of
genetic engineering Paul Berg had done
some of his experiments and it was clear
that we were gonna eventually be able to
do all kinds of very subtle things with
biology and to let this new science
loose on the problem of winning Wars
which basically nowadays means not only
in the field against soldiers but also
against the civilians back home
it's an awful prospect so for these two
reasons one it's a terrible thing to do
very awful in my own science and second
that the argument against it is it
absolutely a reputable this should be
easy to get rid of it to convince them
and now who could who who could stop it
the only one person as far as the United
States is concerned the president they
could say we're gonna renounce it okay
so the problem is to get by now we have
Kennedy assassinated the same year that
I was in Washington and then we had
Johnson and during this time I went
around trying to convince high officials
for example I went to McGeorge Bundy who
was president of the Kennedys and then
President Johnson's national security
adviser but he was the Dean who had
hired me in Harvard and I knew him
pretty well and told him what I thought
he agreed completely this is a lousy
thing to be doing but he said we were so
busy we don't have time to get rid of it
but I promise you it will never be in
the war plans I've never seen a war plan
so I went around and I talked to the
highest officials I could get to know I
went to various people in the Congress
in the House and the Senate made close
relationships wherever I talked people
would say yeah that's right so I created
an atmosphere you had to create some
degree of well there's an anecdote about
President Roosevelt someone came to him
with in that friend of his with a plan
and Roosevelt told him
it's a good idea I agree with it but now
go put pressure on me in other words a
president might do something on his own
but it's a lot easier if he can be doing
something which is likely to be met with
general approval so how do you do that
well the friend up here in Cambridge
told me I should go down to the
Washington Post and meet the managing
editor
Howard Simons the man by the way who
introduced deep throat to Woodworth and
Carl Bernstein so that was how he
Simon's eat when I told him I wanted to
get a lot of newspaper coverage of this
question he took out a yellow pad and
wrote down the names of maybe 30 science
journalists and newspapers these days
newspapers most newspapers don't any
longer have science journalists because
they're having to save money but some do
but in those days lots did and I
contacted nearly every one of those
people went to see him I wrote to them
talk to him that got a lot of press
coverage and then there were television
television interviews Mike Wallace's
program so on and so forth so and the
army itself had the army was in charge
of the program made the number of
mistakes and some accidents and things
like that
Quakers were boycotting Fort Dietrich so
there was some publicity and in the
house and the Senate there was quite a
bit and then at one point soon after
Henry Kissinger became a security
adviser to Nixon Mel Laird who was the
secretary of defense said Henry a letter
saying dear Henry I think we should
review our policies for chemical and
biological weapons because I'm getting a
lot of complaint and questioning from
congressman McCarthy and Senator
Fulbright these are the two men I had
been working with for several years on
this and the reason they were asking
these questions was because we were
working together so everything sort of
came together and the spark plug was the
letter from from there but there
wouldn't have happened if I don't think
it would have happened unless so he had
felt
the questioning coming from the Congress
he himself had been a congressman so
President Nixon's well Henry asked him
to it ordered a major study of this and
the different branches of government
came up with their different points of
view defense separate point of view from
the Joint Chiefs State Department actor
and so on and in the end President Nixon
went all the way he renounced chemical
and biological weapons we announced
their development position transfer and
the whole bit
and then the question came up of
something which is not alive but made by
living things namely toxins like toxins
made by bacteria botulinum toxin or by
snakes and so on and there had been some
interest at Fort Detrick of making these
things into weapons and the question
came up what about those and so there
was a whole independent review of that I
wrote some papers about that for
Kissinger and that the one of the papers
I wrote I know made up President Nixon's
mine because Kissinger tried to reach me
the night that President made that
decision I was out at a friend's house
for dinner with my wife but Henry then
called
it's a long story but anyway Henry said
that they found my paper there in Key
Biscayne where they were as that that
made it up the president's mind he would
renounce toxins no matter how they're
made whether they're made by living
things or by chemists in factories and
so that put toxins and living biological
weapons in the same category the United
States renounced them both President
Nixon also at that same time expressed
support for the British draft treaty it
was a British treaty not ours to
prohibit biological weapons to which we
added toxins a worldwide and some years
later that Trujillo came into force
after a considerable negotiation it has
no inspector well it has inspection
provision but only under very special
circumstances basically without
inspection
but a lot of people don't understand how
you can have a treaty with no inspection
of course having inspection is even
better but to have a treaty with even
the remote possibility of inspection can
have an effect when a country isn't dead
sure of what it wants to do so imagine a
group of people sitting around a room
should we have biological weapons half
of them say no first of all we don't
need them
it's dangerous cetera et cetera and half
of them say well always we should do
this and then someone says look there's
a possibility they're gonna come and
look and since we signed a treaty and
they find something it's a political
risk we don't want to take in other
words the debate if there's a debate of
course if they're dead set on doing it
you're out of luck but if there's any
kind of debate and the most questions
like this they'll be debate within a
government because they have only a
certain amount of resources how are they
going to spend them and usually Armed
Forces don't like biological weapons
they're unpredictable you don't know how
many airplanes to fly to deliver them
and as bombs you don't know exactly what
effect they'll have on people they are a
repugnant to many people using disease
as a weapon so there's a lot going for
you if what you want to do is keep
biology from being used or at least
disease remains as a weapon so really
all I did was to be in the right place
at the right time and be the right
person and it was easy
I spent I'd say half of my life in those
years and the other half doing research
and teaching here but it took a lot of
there are a lot of people to make
contact with to get things going in the
right direction and they like you said
this is your science biology and you
wanted it to be used for the betterment
of humankind and not yeah well not just
because it was mine because it had this
special prospect so even nuclear weapons
they blow you up
they don't change
biology has the potential to change
humanity not Mike just killing was
disease but far more sophisticated
applications would be sure to come if
year after year after year major powers
were working on better and better
biological weapons so yes
and it happens surreptitiously and the
cost being so low given in nickel to
produce something like this is just
horrid no for people who might be
watching us talking like this I must say
don't worry about this too much you got
a lot of other things to worry about
especially climate change I'll tell you
why you should be too worried there are
lots of things we could be worried about
but we have to use history as some kind
yes it's more than a decade ago quite a
bit more then we had the anthrax letter
attacks there hasn't been a single
copycat in all these years even though
it showed it can be done it works it
killed people so if in the entire wide
world this hasn't happened again it's
not the main thing that ordinary people
need to worry about there are people in
our government whose job it is to think
about remedies in case it should ever
happen and there are people in our
government who try to keep a close watch
on what other people are doing and there
are even people in our government
we'll keep a watch on what we're doing
but this is not something for the man in
the street to worry about anymore
I would say because let's look at
history there we know that climate
change is happening for sure we know
that there are big political changes
happening for sure and if nothing has
happened in the way of even bioterrorism
for all these years you know might be in
the papers tomorrow morning but you've
got other things in a more important to
worry about we're taking what you did as
a template for how to
vent existential threats and just
mitigate risk of causing unnecessary
suffering and just inspire more global
cohesion we're taking what you did the
biological weapons convention being
signed on April 10th 1972 recently
celebrated its 47th anniversary and by
ending the use of biological weaponry
worldwide we're able to live in a more
prosperous civilization for centuries to
come and so we need to do similar
templating for for all of the pressing
issues that we're facing moving forward
and so it's it's it's a it's one of the
most critical things a hundred and
eighty-two member states with the treaty
and so if we can keep doing that for the
treaties to inspire global cohesion what
these pressing challenges that we face
that's one of the best ways moving
forward it's a great template and just
for people to know about people like you
people to know about people like Vasili
arkhipov and stanislav petrov the
previous 2017 and 2018 future of life
award winners that you are our role
models you are the leaders that we need
to look up to in the past that helped us
get to a deeper state of global cohesion
and we need to take some of the
attention that's happening in this
massive pool of the internet and
redirect it towards towards templates
like what you guys did Ellen I of course
agree exactly with what you said there
are two things I'd like to comment on
one you can't call it a template it was
a very special situation so the extent
that is that template the template would
be this that it would be good to
interest more young scientists in the
ways in which they could contribute to
making the world safer safer not just
for existence but for progress and the
other thing is that there never has been
any biological warfare so listeners or
viewers shouldn't get the impression
that there had been biological warfare
no but there had been preparations for
it that's what has been stopped
we have a lot of millennial and Gen Z
talent of these young people that have
access to the in this infinite abundance
of knowledge within this internet
through the devices that are so
sophisticated and for us to be able to
galvanize around causes that prevent
hiccups in the future is so so critical
why don't we go ahead and on on this way
of closing I just have a couple things
that I want you to share about I think
that in 1979 there was a process of
solving the speared lofts anthrax
mystery teaches about what that was and
how you will be in April of 1979 in
first couple of weeks of May people died
in this Soviet city of trade loss which
is just east of the Ural Mountains from
anthrax we didn't learn about that
really until about a year after it
happened and we learned about that from
refugees coming out and from other
sources and so the CIA began to look
into it the Russian government when
queried said that it was due to an
outbreak of anthrax amongst animals
cattle and sheep and that the button
black-market meat had caused
gastrointestinal anthrax of those who
consumed the contaminated meat the other
possibility though was that it was an
accident of some sort at a biological
facility military biological facility
which we knew at that time already was
located in the city of spirit logic so
the question was what was it was it bad
meat or was it an aerosol that his
particles in the air released by
accident and so I was asked by the CIA
to come down there and work together
with a small group who were working on
this I spent about a week living down
there I was fortunate in that the man
who was running this investigation had
$2.00 who were away at college
and since there were no hotels near
Langley at that time I lived in his
house and it was able to talk to him
about this problem and breakfast and
dinner of course the only the
unclassified parts as well as working on
the classified parts every weekday so I
really got to know about everything
about this and at the end of all of this
the conclusion of our working group was
not that it was certain that it was
there born but that it was probable that
it was airborne we had to draw a
conclusion that was either possible
probable or confirmed and the group said
what problems I'm a reason that's too
technical to go into now I find myself
wondering still what it was it happened
and so in my opinion the best thing that
they was though they're in luck but you
could say it's very naive is a cold war
out of 100 people that approximately
died we think of we know then we know
the names of 68 and we also couldn't
pass it couldn't have possibly opened up
the gastrointestinal tract to see if
that was the kid watching - from Sir
lorsque who's me yeah this is the
question okay yeah so that's exactly
right
so I decided the way it's just like we
need to go to Russia to see what things
are like when I was a kid so I decided I
have to get there and look I have to
bring a team of specialists and go
investigate
you think that's very naive but I met a
very high-level Russian in Geneva a man
who sits on their military Industrial
Commission which make all the basic
technical decisions on how to spend
money in the defense sector his name was
Carol DeMaio and I asked him about this
he said yes I will arrange for you to
come and though I went to the CIA and
said look if I do get an invitation to
go I need a map because maybe they'll
try to take me to the wrong place give
me a map actually the math the CIA had
at the time was wrong it would have gone
to the wrong place anyway
I got a letter back though from this mr.
du Maya by this time there is Soviet air
jet had shot down the Korean jet if any
of you remember that everybody died and
so I got a letter from mr. DeMaio saying
because of that at this time they
couldn't invite me after all I don't
know if they ever would have really then
later a friend of mine here at Harvard
Medical School shared a Nobel price with
the Russian the Soviet Minister of
Defense chess off and burn Elon was the
American and I knew Bernie so I said
Bernie when you go to Moscow ask chess
off if I could go to spare lost
he's the Minister of Health so he did
and when Bernie came back he said Chazz
off says you can go so I said it telex
touches off the Russian militsiya
Minister of Health
saying I'm ready to go here's my team
etc for four or five of us then I got
back a telex saying well he had said
someone down there to look and there was
no evidence left all gone
I could go to some other Russian city if
I wanted but not spared loss I wrote
back saying well look scientists always
finds some something good comes out of
meeting each other and so on
I'd still like to go to spirit law so I
never heard back but then Boris Yeltsin
comes along Soviet Union goes away we
have the Russian Republic instead and I
read in the in those days I used to read
the digests put out by the CIA of the
Russian press and there I read that a
certain mr. you block off had been
ordered by President Yeltsin to look
into this epidemic well I knew this
mystery Holocaust he had visited the
United States and we had talked about
this epidemic in Sverdlovsk
and I'd expressed to him my interest in
finding out about it so I said in
italics to him I see that you've been
asked by Yeltsin your president to look
into this I'd like to come help you and
I'd like to go to Speer Loski so he
writes back inside you can't do that
well it's too long ago you wouldn't find
anything and then the a visiting Russian
came here man named x-ray by coin said
sir law few genes fear loss and he's
staying at a friend's house
Alex rich a very good molecular
biologist no longer alive and Alex
Rich's wife comes to me at this party
from
la francaise sir it looks a very nice
guy he's been with us for about a week I
make his breakfast I make the bed he's
very nice guy but maybe you could invite
him to stay at your house instead for a
while so we did we made his breakfast we
made his bed and I told him about mr.
Noblet olive and I wanted to go to Sri
Lanka he said I'm a pal of his I will
fix things for you so a little while
later I get a letter from mr. Noblet
cough but now it's from Washington he's
accompanying he's accompanying Yeltsin
to Washington when he also made that
speech before the Congress no more lies
and he writes now and hi Regency Hotel
stationery okay you can come change but
you still need to be invited by somebody
so who do I know in spare loss this
whole thing is a story of accidents
amazing so the next accident is who do I
know in Sverdlovsk well it turns out
that there had been an American
physicist working there during the
epidemic on the United States National
Academy of Sciences Russian Academy of
Sciences exchange doing solid-state
physics there this is a guy named Don
Ellis from Northwestern University in
Chicago so I called up Don Ellis who I
knew and said Don I need someone to
invite me to spare loss and you work
together with a Russian physicist named
gubanov could you ask him to invite me
and Don said I don't need to he's
visiting me today I'll just hand him the
phone gubanov comes on the phone I tell
him I need you to invite me to spare
lost he said no problem I've always
believed my wife we've been interested
in that epidemic all these years
I'll get you an invitation so in a few
days I get a telex from the rector of
the local university a mathematical
physicist and he says the city is you
this was when Americans were very
popular even loved in Russia a brief
time and the city is yours so I sent the
information what we wanted to do there
well there were four of us etc I brought
a pathologist who could
look at that what was we could find left
of last slides and organs in bottles of
formaldehyde or alcohol
I brought a veterinary doctor because
anthrax is primarily a disease of
animals
I brought a Russian woman who had been a
nurse at Sverdlovsk at that time she was
living in Moscow I didn't bring her from
the United States but she was part of
our group and my wife was an
anthropologist to question people and we
would interview there so the main thing
we did was to ask people we had a list
of 68 people who died and the reason we
had that is that there was a woman who
was a friend of Yeltsin at the time but
now she's elected to their Duma which is
like our Congress and she had written
you know you note several letters saying
dear Boris Nikolayevich those people
whose friends and relatives died of
anthrax deserve extra pension money just
like people who died in war relatives
the people who died in war I need to
know the names I need to know if this
was a state act this epidemic and if it
was I need to have the names of those
who died because those peoples would get
extra pen double pension so that was
done and she was given a list of 68
names from Yeltsin of the people who
died and where they were living at the
time so my wife and two Russian
professors women from the local
university went door by door knocked on
the doors and the main thing we asked we
asked a lot of questions I never took
part we thought it would be better for
women to do this less confrontational
perhaps yeah most was this person likely
to be working at night or in the day or
if they weren't working were they
pensioners living at home so then we can
make two maps on a spot satellite
photograph of the city and like each
person we don't wouldn't know for sure
where they were likely to be but we knew
with some probability so at night all
the people who were daytime workers and
all the pensioners were likely to be at
home with sleeping and in the date
the pensioners were still likely to be
at home puttering around I guess
and they time they'd be at the place of
employment so we could make two
different maps add a map and a night map
and they were very different the night
map nearly all these 68 people mapped as
big region south of is in the southern
part of the city but in the day time map
nearly all of these 68 points are in a
zone a very narrow zone going from the
place which we knew to be a military
biological facility south to the very
end of the city city limits and then we
had the names of five villages were
sheep and cattle had died and all of
these points are in a straight line and
then I had meteorological data because
the Russians were members of the World
Meteorological Organization and they'd
reported wind direction at the local
sphere lost airport every three hours
back in the back before 1979 so we had
all this information there was one day
and only one day April 4th 1979 when the
wind was blowing in the same direction
all day and that direction was the same
as the direction now bad meat does not
get blown in straight lines but a cloud
does so that solved that we published
that in science magazine no question it
was airborne so I'd like using science
to solve this kind of problem we did the
same thing in Vietnam we did the same
thing in the case of what's called a
yellow rain where it was the West the
United States that was accusing the
Soviets of using a toxin weapon in Laos
against among tribes people it turned
out that this so-called yellow rain was
the defecation from huge flights of
honeybees it was all a big mistake
there was no toxin warfare so the
scientific things I've done related arms
control one showed that the Soviets were
totally wrong but in that case I think
they some of them knew that they were
wrong and in this case I don't think we
knew that our explanation was wrong we
just had done bad science and the third
thing about the Asian orange was
a different nature I went to Vietnam
with a team at the request of the
American Academy ricchan Association for
the Advancement of science during the
war to study or to create a pilot study
of the ecological and medical effects of
the herbicide spraying and it was very
interesting the theme that continues to
come up is the solving of the
complicated questions with all as much
evidence as you can find evidence is the
key word that's right
did I send you the thing before I wrote
about the herbicides
it's called from Charles and Francis
Darwin to Richard Nixon the origin and
termination of the use of anti plant
chemical warfare look at what's called
the post grip there because just before
and I was there for six weeks 60 I think
six weeks the last day general Abrams
who was the commander of US forces in
Vietnam
and the after general westmoreland Oh
asked me to come over to tonsillar where
his office was they just come back from
a gallbladder surgery and Japan so he's
kind of laid back we spent the whole
morning talking in the course of it he
said what do you think of the military
utility of the herbicides we didn't
study then he said you want to know what
I think and I must have said something
like yes sir and he said I think there's
[ __ ] you know I said well why are we
using them and he said you don't
understand anything about this war young
man that was young man he said that
order comes from Washington and I can't
do anything about it and if I didn't
have the stuff used it was 55-gallon
drums would pile up on the ducks at
Denning and Saigon and I couldn't
offload this stuff I need so this was a
very vivid memory but I wanted to
include it in this thing I've written at
that time he told me that his son John
who was a captain up in I Corps that's
that
part agreed with him exactly about her
besides being useless or
counterproductive so I located turns out
general Abrams had four boys four sons
they all became checklist I think three
of them even became four-star generals
but John was a four-star general you've
risen from captain
he's a owns a little consulting company
in Washington got him on the phone I
said is my memory right did your dad
thinks his stuff was [ __ ] and did you
agree with him he said he just he almost
blew us he said much worse than that he
was really in fact so I know my memory
was right and I thanked him at the end
of my paper I read so hear the damn
stuff was actually helping us lose the
war but the people in Washington I can
tell you an anecdote in like this one
day I was up in I Corps and quaint I
promise that's the fifth one down from
the topic of forty provinces and I'm
staying overnight there in a base and
each of the provinces had what's called
an American senior advisor sort of the
representative of the United States at
the local level and every morning there
would be a report from a long-range
patrol if there had been a long-range
patrol and there had been the previous
night and it was run by a captain and he
reports what he'd seen he and his men
were up in the woods and they saw
buckets hanging from limbs of trees a
lot of buckets he said a man climbing up
to bring one down and he reported to our
little group and as far as they could
see it was mud and piss and he didn't
know what it meant and the province
senior advisor a man named Hank Cushing
said he knew what it meant because he'd
been informed from Saigon it turns out
that of course the big problem in the
war was finding the enemy because we had
superior firepower if we knew where they
were and some genius figured out that
these men of course must urinate on the
ground and the urea in urine is
converted by soil bacteria into ammonia
gas and that rises and ammonia has three
hydrogen's with an
in the middle and the three hydrogens go
back and forth like that and cause a
very very intense absorption line in the
infrared so with an infrared
spectrometer you can detect the tiniest
amounts of ammonia in the air so we
invented a thing called the people
sniffer and mounted on helicopters now
these people sniffers flying around
Vietnam looking for ammonia gas and when
they find it they call him the the the
gunships the helicopter gunship and they
blast that area oh there's something
there's men down there of course it
could be an elephant because they
urinate too but so what are these
buckets it's because the same brain it's
in the skulls of American defense
planners that seemed kind of a brain is
in the skulls of the Vietnamese guys so
they had figured out that what this
plane is looking for is ammonia gas and
it's made by mixing your urine with mud
and so if we hang buckets of urine with
mud and on the trees the people sniffer
is going to come flying by and we'll
blow it out of the sky and that's why we
lost nearly all the people's sniffers
because of the same mind that divides
this people sniffer understood it and
used it turned it around 180 degrees and
the lesson here is that people who were
far away from a war may have a very
distorted idea of what's going on both
politically and in this case militarily
and physically it's the people on the
scene who know what's going on and so
never forget that we kept on supporting
the war because we had that is our
people in our Congress my president we
had a completely distorted idea Henry
Kissinger when he made his first trip to
Vietnam before President Nixon came into
office came back and told us at Harvard
and a seminar that he thought that we
were losing badly and didn't see much
prospect of doing much better
so that was because he didn't go on a
tour
they just show you what they want you to
see he went he stayed that I think six
weeks and talk to people in low levels
and so it's very important we started
with the word evidence yeah it's very
important to get to the evidence and not
just to the talk yeah if it's an
important question and it's critical to
get to a state of global cohesion and
unity I'm curious as to where can where
do you where do you think that we can go
geopolitically to get to that state of
cohesion and unity I don't know I don't
know I think most physical scientists
biological scientists are brought up
with this idea but that doesn't
guarantee their objectivity but I think
that if you took some kind of test you'd
find them to be someone more objective
than people who get elected to public
office oh that's a problem
people who get elected to public office
very often in the past motivated by
wanting to serve the country and not by
personal ambition I may be wrong about
that but that's my impression it's too
bad if I'm right it would be too bad the
reason for wanting to run for public
office is to serve the country and not
just to serve a particular clique in the
country if I serve the country so how do
you do that I guess
teaching civics in high school or even
grammar school is one way to because
there are certain kids out there who
might get inspired but by the idea of
serving your country as a representative
or as a member of the administration or
the Congress but we don't teach civics
much anymore I don't have any I don't
have answers to your big questions
I've been worried about a few specific
questions in my life but that doesn't
mean you can transfer that to everything
else we love asking the guests the big
questions and seeing what their thoughts
are another big question we like asking
is what do you think is a skill that
children should know going into the
exponential technology age try to go to
the source of fats if you can talk with
people of different views um trying to
educate yourself trying not to be swayed
by emotion don't believe everything
don't believe what the majority of
people for example we've gone through
this whole thing about whether President
Trump was in collusion with the Soviet
with the Russian government and a very
famous detective really Muller at the
FBI Spears and the answer is no he
wasn't but in the meantime I'm afraid
that the Washington Post in the New York
Times and many other journalist sources
actually acted as though it was a proven
thing and so we could end with the lousy
journalism really lousy and basically
why was it it was because of groupthink
and and believing what you wanted to be
true I think they went overboard and
have ruined their reputation even though
these are the newspapers I love used to
love but I think there are other cases
too were groupthink has become and on
the other side of the political spectrum
as well we've precipitated out into
different subgroups more than more than
I remember of years ago I don't have a
magic formula those were all those were
all really good points for young people
and two last ones Matthew are we in a
simulation you mean is there an
alternative universe that is well it's
an interesting possibility and only
recently have there been sound physical
reasons to think there could be multiple
universes if that's what you mean
whether or not it would be possible to
communicate between them as you probably
know if there are multiple universes we
don't know at least I've never read of
any way in which they can communicate
with each other such that we would be a
hologram of it's fascinating
what's happening in cosmology now is
absolutely fantastic we're beginning to
understand more and more about what made
the Big Bang the way it was last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
box double violin played by Heifetz and
Menuhin it's very beautiful box box six
sweets for unaccompanied cello played by
pablo casals or by a negro those through
those works of music there are lots of
things birds babies stars Matthew thank
you so much for coming on to the show
joining us teaching us I really
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you they real-life we only touch oh yeah
and you and this is another thing is
that the whole elbows further serious
because in the amount of germs that are
spread you take the influenza epidemic
of 1918 it spread with an incredible
speed jumping from country to country
because people traveled even then well
now people travel orders of magnitude
more frequently and if you have
something on your hands that's in
Singapore a few hours later it's in New
York and a few hours later
COGO so why not just touch elbows and
well on an evolutionary question as well
part of the reason that we've built so
much in civilizations because we did it
with our hands and so that I've never
thought about that and so that's one of
the reasons why we bond with other
people I thought the reason was to show
that we don't have a gun potentially
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode go and talk more about
what we talked about with Matthew we
talked to Matthew about so many things
regarding genetics about molecular
biology we talked so much about the
biological weapons convention and about
mitigating existential risk share this
with your family your friends your
co-workers with people online check out
Matthew's links below as well support
the organizations the entrepreneurs in
the in the artists that you believe in
around the world supports simulation so
he can keep doing cool things like
coming to Cambridge to do interviews and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace